men are object oriented women are
subject oriented so what happens is when
you've got like a Hillary Clinton and
like a Barack Obama Obama sees a map and
on the map he sees a military base and
he says I think we should uh what that
military base and then like oh let's get
let's confer with Hillary what she
thinks and Hillary says we should blow
up those people yeah so you see what I'm
saying like Obama is targeting some
object of some Merit and Hillary is like
I hate them blow them up so you said
women are evils
at least she's being honest about what's
going to happen the uh but the what it
is it really is it shows it shines a
light on the toxic positivity that this
is what Hollywood and all of these
industries push is like it's an
unrealistic expectation of how human
beings interact and invariably just like
men behind the scenes uh a bad you know
a bad tour manager a bad boss a bad
celebrity is not is not restricted to
one gender or one person